the movie king richard i sure hope
you've seen it tells a powerful story
about the early lives of two icons of
american sports that of course are
tennis superstars venus and serena
williams and their parents now richard
is her father played in the film by will
smith anjanu ellis is knockout she plays
her mom or a scene twice in this scene
she makes sure that he knows that if
he's a king she's the queen
you never believed in none of this when
did i not believe
i want you to tell me when did i not
believe you're not the only dreamer in
this family
wouldn't be no dream if it wasn't for me
i carry them inside me and on my back
and i carried you too
working two shifts so i could put food
on your table
that open stance
you got that from me oh you did that oh
okay
and i fixed serena serve because you
messed that up you did what yes i fixed
that toss because you messed it up i'm
here i've been here dreaming and
believing just like you you just don't
want to see me
oh it's such a great scene anjanu ellis
hello you're getting some well-deserved
oscar buzz for that performance joining
us now good morning to you anja new
ellis it's so good to see you
it's so good to see you too good morning
good morning good morning yeah we're all
excited to talk to you this is the thing
when i watch the movie i had no idea the
role that oracine price played in the
careers of her daughters number one i
didn't even know that she played tennis
you see her at the matches and she's
sitting in the stands what did you think
about that
i felt that i felt a little bit of a
little bit of a fool really you know
when i was doing my initial
research i looked her up and i saw that
she described herself as a coach
and i i really had kind of a
condescending reaction to that that that
was her estimation of herself was a
coach she was a mother cheering on her
daughters that does not a coach make but
then when i got the job and um
found out
the the the the truth of miss oracine's
journey with her daughters and with her
husband she was absolutely her coach
their coach and she trained herself
to teach her daughters how to play while
she was working two jobs and being their
brother
and anjanu uh this movie is getting a
lot of oscar buzz
what would it feel like to be nominated
you know
here's the thing that is something that
is completely out of my hands
right and
i i just i i can't it's out of my
control
so let me just say for me honestly this
might sound a little corny but i don't
care
i'm just so excited that i'm a part of
something that gives
us this country a chance to give miss
orcing price her flowers yes yeah
because i was like you guys you know
just seeing her
you know what i mean and just seeing her
in the stands and with those fashionable
glasses on and looking cute you know
but she look at her you know she's just
she her imprint on the sport of tennis
and sports as we know it in this country
is is priceless
so
that's that's exciting to me that is
exciting
and she was necessary as one little girl
wrote to you in a letter uh and this
movie corrects the record on that and it
does so in part because of that amazing
scene in the kitchen you go head-to-head
with mr richard king richard uh will
smith uh how much of that was scripted
and how much is that was that you just
being in character in the moment
that was all scripted that was all
scripted um we worked on that scene and
we worked on that scene and we worked on
that scene up until
just that morning
um because we wanted to get those words
right um
because i've
been accomplished
yeah i think and for me you know they're
going to be so many more movies that are
going to be done about venus and serena
when we're all dead and gone right
because great writers look to those
kinds of figures to tell those epic
figures to tell epic stories but how
many times are we going to get a chance
to tell ms orsin's prize story
while she's alive
i want to tell your story in 30 seconds
or less on janu because you said before
you take any role you ask yourself three
questions what are they one two three
please
do i wanna wake up in the morning and go
to work to do it
am i gonna make my family am i gonna
embarrass my family if i do it i may but
hey you know
um are they gonna be happy at the end
results and
oh god i don't know
no no will i get a chance to talk to
gayle king at the end of this oh yes
yeah and will it be a service of black
women let me just tell you something
mission accomplished for you we are
cheering you on oscar nominations coming
up very soon i sure hope they call out
your name thank you
next time
that'll do it for us cheering you on
we'll see you tomorrow on cbs morning